We have reached a kind of inflection point in the privacy debate because what we know based on this pandemic
is there is gonna be a lot more people sheltered at home. And from the moment they get up in the morning
until the moment they go to bed at night, the internet is arguably the biggest aspect of their life
in terms of communicating with people. They shouldn't have their most intimate information spied on,
snooped over by the federal government without warning.
Before the Senate voted to reauthorize the USA Freedom Act, formerly known as the Patriot Act,
on May 14th. Oregon Senator Ron Wyden fought a losing battle to rein in the broad authority that it gives
US intelligence agencies to spy on the web activities of American citizens.
I think it would be hugely chilling in terms of people's ability to freely access the information
that they most want to see that is private and personal.
It might be your dating history, it might be religious beliefs, it might be your fears, the most private data.
It's like data mining of somebody's thoughts. The Democrat Wyden, along with his Republican colleague,
Steve Daines tried attaching an amendment to the bill that would have explicitly banned government agents
from collecting Americans web search histories without a warrant from a FISA Court.
Now an anti surveillance activist group called Fight for the Future is trying to
convince a Nancy Pelosi and
congressional Democrats to add the same
amendment to the House version of the
bill but in a political world where
Democrats regularly called the president
a power abusing authoritarian in the
making the president has engaged in
abuse of power
undermining our national security our
democracy is at peril and Republicans
bolon a deep state plot to take down
trump it looks to me like another deep
state attack Democrats are working
together with the deep state to
discredit the duly elected president of
the United States
there's still only weak support for
concrete measures to rein in the post
9/11 surveillance state Nancy Pelosi has
spent the last several years saying that
this administration is dangerous she
impeached the president for abuse of
power if she doesn't take this
opportunity to get this amendment in
place that at least puts some limit on
this administration surveillance
Authority it's hard not to feel like the
entire resistance rhetoric has been a
bit of a scam
Evan Grier is fight for the futures
deputy director she literally can just
tack on this amendment it'll get
it'll go back to the Senate it'll pass
the Senate and we can actually get one
small piece of this mess fixed once and
for all
but Greer says congressional leaders
have shown little interest in
restricting the power of US intelligence
agencies there's actually a lot of
appetite from members of both parties to
rein in some of these overly broad
surveillance programs and it has been
leadership on both sides Nancy Pelosi
Adam Schiff on the Democratic side Mitch
McConnell on the Republican side has
been incredibly Pro surveillance
really it has been leadership that have
repeatedly undermined good-faith
attempts to reform some of these laws to
bring them up to date to protect
people's privacy this is fundamentally a
question of whether officials like Bill
Barr should have the authority to in
effect spy on law-abiding Americans
these millions of people who newly spend
many many hours a day at home sheltering
in place their privacy rights shouldn't
just be you know tossed aside senator
Wyden has often been sort of a bit of a
canary in the coalmine on things like
this in terms of he'll ask very specific
questions of intelligence officials when
they come on it on the hill that sort of
get at some of these things Greer says
widens introduction of the amendment
could be a way of alerting the public
that intelligence agencies have already
been collecting US citizens web search
data Wyden can't say it explicitly
because that information would be
classified does the NSA collect any type
of data at all on millions or hundreds
of millions of Americans it would be a
repeat of what happened in 2013 when
Wyden questioned Director of National
Intelligence James clapper with the
intention of tipping off the public that
the government was engaged in bulk
collection of phone data no sir it does
not
not wittingly I know that often you're
dealing with classified information so
you might be limited and what you can
speak to but is there any reason to
believe that this is actually happening
I can't get into intelligence matters
but just yesterday I inquired as to that
data whether we can get it what it's
being used for and we can make that kind
of information public because I believe
there's a reporting requirement Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell opposed
Wyden in the Senate claiming that
additional limitations to the nation's
surveillance laws would jeopardize
important tools that keep America safe
first of all death just flatly
inaccurate Wyden says his amendment
addresses McConnell's national security
concerns because in a crisis
law enforcement agencies would still be
allowed to gather intelligence before
obtaining a warrant if someone in law
enforcement believes that there is a
bomb outside Louisville law enforcement
can go and immediately collect the
information that is needed to protect
the people and come back after and the
fact and settle up on the warrant so I
think that alone shows why Mitch
McConnell's arguments off-base a more
modest Senate amendment requiring FISA
courts here analysis from opposing
parties such as the ACLU was included in
the version of the bill that passed I
have an amendment that would take
Americans out of it I don't think it's
constitutional to invest Americans
particularly American campaigns with a
secret court I think it uses a less than
constitutional standard but Rand Paul's
more radical effort to eliminate the
surveillance of American citizens
altogether without a warrant from an on
FISA Court was defeated even Wyden voted
against it Senator Paul started an
important conversation with respect to
whether the whole framework needs to be
reconsidered so this a conversation that
I consider very important and I've told
them that right now I think I've got my
hands full trying to make the many
reforms that are needed in FISA
immediately Grier encourages anyone
concerned about government surveillance
of what citizens are searching for on
the web to call Nancy Pelosi Zhou
and pressure her to put a version of the
widened Danes amendment one of which is
reportedly being drafted by
representative Zoe Lofgren and
representative Warren Davidson back in
the bill will give you a short script of
kind of what to say and we'll connect
you directly to speaker Pelosi's office
this is incredibly relevant to the
situation that we're in now and it's
really important that we remind
lawmakers that the public does care
about our right to be free from overly
broad and intrusive surveillance
you